ladies and gentlemen welcome to the very
core the center of the City of London a
walking tool with a difference we're
bringing into these ancient alleyways
and I think they're very symbolic you
are still within the center of the most
important commercial center in the world
but you wouldn't imagine it would you
from here only when you go behind the
scenes do you realize just how integral
this square mile is to the UK economy
most of the world's trades in foreign
exchange would end up somehow coming
through London bullion dealing the
majority of the world's bullion it dealt
the price is indeed set within the City
of London now as ever this place is
built on trust trust that one bank can
safely exchange money with another if
people were to face a shortage of euros
or dollars the Bank of England would
need to borrow those euros and dollars
from the ECB from the Federal Reserve
without these so-called swaps the
financial system simply wouldn't be able
to function this is the plumbing the
architectural plumbing that underlies
the international monetary and financial
system and whatever one thinks about all
the flaws in that system
these swap lines are necessary so what
are they well remember banks in the city
are constantly shifting money from one
currency into another trillions of
dollars a day the Moriya is if there's a
crisis or a moment of panic say and
no-till brexit these flows might
suddenly dry up
that's where swap lines come in central
banks step in and say they'll guarantee
there'll be enough dollars or Euros to
swap into say pounds that keeps the
money flowing and a system working so
what prize were a crucial kind of quasi
bailout during the financial crisis and
according to insiders the UK would have
to rely on them again in the event of a
heart breaks it but would the European
Central Bank actually play ball one can
never rule out some sort of uncertain
moment where political processes become
so complicated that the ECB would be
told or another central bank or the
Federal Reserve will be told you have to
revoke these swap lines at its horns to
escape the IRA neither if person left
without a deal
in those first few glorious hours of
sovereignty this country's most
important economic sector would have to
fall back upon what mark Connie likes to
call the kindness of strangers and not
just any strangers but the American and
God forbid the European Central Bank
faced with the Magnificent frontage of
both the Bank of England which is there
and the Royal Exchange whatever happens
with the negotiation and there's still
plenty of twists and turns left all eyes
will turn here when Britain leaves in
all sorts of ways still the City of
London it rolls whether it will do so
again in March is the next question at
Conway Sky News